dominante
y
el senado de eeuu aprobó la legalidad
del impeachment contra donald trump el
segundo juicio político contra el
exmandatario acusado de incitación a la
insurrección tras la toma el capitolio
el 6 de enero inició con las alegaciones
de los congresistas demócratas que
ejercen como fiscales y los abogados de
trump tenemos reporte desde washington
la organización de naciones unidas
condenó la violencia policial contra
manifestantes en mianmar durante las
multitudinarias protestas ciudadanas en
contra del golpe de estado del primero
de febrero
el depuesto partido olimpia nacional
para la democracia denunció que la
policía está usando armas de fuego
contra los manifestantes
la presidenta de la comisión europea
reconoció las fallas en la aprobación la
distribución de las vacunas contra el
cob y 19 por parte del bloque
comunitario y señaló que fueron
demasiado optimistas respecto a la
cantidad de vacunas que podían entregar
las farmacéuticas a los 27 países de la
unión tenemos reportes desde bruselas
hola muy buen día bienvenidos a las
noticias en france 24 sierra blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en eeuu donde el senado aprobó la
legalidad del segundo juicio por
impeachment al ex presidente de donald
trump acusado de incitar a la
insurrección el asalto al capitolio el
pasado 6 de enero la votación fue de 56
votos a favor de los cuales seis fueron
republicanos y 44 en contra
una cifra que anticipa el difícil camino
que tendrán los demócratas para obtener
los 17 votos republicanos necesarios
para condenar a trump ya que se requiere
de una mayoría de dos tercios marina
sardiña nos cuenta cómo fue la primera
jornada realizada este martes
fue un día histórico en eeuu al
iniciarse el segundo juicio político
contra donald trump ex de fort y fue ser
republicanos en el senado se pusieron
del lado de los demócratas para
dictaminar que el proceso es
constitucional por lo tanto pueden
seguir adelante los republicanos habían
argumentado que su amo no puede ser
condenado porque ya no ocupa el cargo
los demócratas dijeron que esa lógica
sienta un peligroso precedente y daría
carta blanca a cualquier presidente para
actuar con impunidad constitucional en
sus últimas semanas en el cargo
y abrieron sus comentarios mostrando un
vídeo de los disturbios del 6 de enero
en el capitolio hecho que llevó a
iniciar el juicio contra el ex
presidente y ahora preguntan qué es un
alto crimen y un delito menor según
nuestra constitución eso es lo que es un
alto crimen y un delito menor si eso no
es un delito jugable entonces no existe
tal cosa
después de la emoción al cierre del
primer argumento fue el turno de los
abogados defensores de trump en un
desconcertante
curso de apertura de 50 minutos el
primer representante legal de sesión no
presentó en su mayoría ninguna
refutación legal a los demócratas de la
cámara de representantes en un momento
dado admitieron que habían cambiado de
táctica tras escuchar los argumentos
iniciales de la oposición luego pasaron
al ataque
entendamos por qué estamos aquí
realmente estamos aquí porque la mayoría
de estas personas no quieren enfrentarse
a donald trump como rival político en el
futuro por eso estamos aquí en el future
otros senadores partidarios de su ámbar
gu mentaron que era el odio hacia el ex
presidente lo que estaba alimentando el
juicio advirtiendo que sólo acabaría
desgarrando el país y como lo habíamos
en el informe esta primera jornada se
dedicó a decidir la constitucionalidad
del impeachment contra donald trump para
determinar si los demócratas tenían
derecho a juzgar a un mandatario que ya
dejó su cargo y para ver qué pasará hoy
vamos a washington con nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez cristóbal
os saludo muy buen día los demócratas
necesitarán los votos de 17 republicanos
para conseguir los dos tercios
necesarios
escaños para así condenar a trump es
decir requieren que los mismos 6 que
votaron ayer lo vuelvan a hacer y que 11
más lo hagan dado así el panorama que
viabilidad tendrá este juicio
es bastante bastante corta la viabilidad
que tiene este juicio político de
prosperar en washington y es que a pesar
de que los la defensa de donald trump
fue bastante floja bastante criticada
ayer y que los demócratas pues tienen
bastantes pruebas a través de vídeos a
través de audios y a través de
documentos pues son muy pocos los
republicanos los que quieren arriesgarse
los senadores republicanos que quieren
arriesgarse a votar en contra de donald
trump porque eso podría afectarles
cualquier interés de reelección que
tengan en sus estados así que en el caso
de marco rubio por ejemplo de la florida
muchos han optado por decir que sí
donald trump va a ser juzgado que sea
juzgado como un ciudadano común y
corriente y no como un expresidente por
eso muchos de ellos podrían votar en
contra del impeachment ahora cristóbal
una vez cumplido el trámite que vimos
ayer que sigue el día de hoy
pues hoy al mediodía se resume es el
segundo día del juicio político y
empieza entonces el líder demócrata el
representante a la cámara gaming rasquín
que está liderando este proceso para la
parte demócrata presentando entonces los
argumentos nuevamente de por qué debería
ser juzgado como presidente y pues es
destituido de una forma simbólica para
entonces después aspirar a que se vote
para que el 28 no pueda volver a aspirar
a un cargo público tendrán 16 horas
entonces los demócratas 16 horas después
tendrán la defensa de donald trump
después de eso vendrán las preguntas de
los senadores después se citará entonces
a testigos y después se hará la votación
final pero pues el líder demócrata y el
líder republicano del senado es ok
summer y mitch mcconnell se reunieron
ayer y han acordado que van a hacer que
este juicio sea bastante rápido se
piensa que de pronto
a eso de el 15 de febrero podría
terminar este juicio según lo acordaron
estos dos líderes del senado y así
entonces tendremos un juicio que durará
muy pocos días a comparación de los 21
días que duró el juicio político pasado
del expresidente de donoso que estaba de
gracias por toda la información que
tenga usted un feliz día vamos a mianmar
donde la oficina de naciones unidas en
especial sudeste asiático condenó la
violencia ejercida por la policía en
respuesta a las manifestaciones
pacíficas en contra del gobierno militar
que tomó el poder la semana pasada tras
un golpe de estado en varias ciudades
como la capital naypyidaw o mandalay la
segunda urbe más poblada las autoridades
usaron cañones de agua gases
lacrimógenos balas de goma y hasta
munición real para tratar de dispersar a
los manifestantes causando varios
heridos al menos siete personas han
resultado heridas tres de ellas de
gravedad entretanto la sede el partido
político liga nacional para la
democracia fue allanada por las fuerzas
de seguridad luego de la entrada en
vigor del toque de queda nocturno
a nuestra hermana le dispararon con
munición real su estado es crítico en
estos momentos ahora vemos que los
militares están actuando brutalmente
contra nosotros pero nosotros los
jóvenes lideramos la protesta de todas
las formas pacíficas seguiremos luchando
contra el régimen bajo nuestro lema la
dictadura militar debe fracasar
en otras noticias la presidenta de la
comisión europea usura von der layen es
reconocido esta mañana que bruselas fue
demasiado optimista respecto a la
cantidad de vacunas que podían entregar
las farmacéuticas a los 27 países del
bloque y dijo que subestimaron las
dificultades que lleva la producción en
masa nuestra corresponsal en bruselas
esther herrera nos entrega los detalles
de estas declaraciones
úrsula von der leyen ha defendido su
gestión sobre su estrategia de
vacunación en la unión europea después
de varias semanas de críticas furibundas
por la gestión y distribución de las
vacunas por toda la unión europea
especialmente después de que la
farmacéutica astrazéneca anunciara que
solo podría enviar un 50 por ciento de
las dosis inicialmente previstas para la
unión europea aún así un sola razón de
legend ha defendido que la estrategia de
vacunación de comprar vacunas
conjuntamente entre todos los países de
la unión europea es una historia de
éxito porque de lo contrario si no se
hubiese hecho así grandes países de la
unión europea hubiesen podido comprar
grandes cantidades de vacunas dejando al
resto sin poniendo en peligro el
proyecto europeo de dos formas úrsula
von der leyen cree que la unión europea
pecó de excesivo optimismo a la hora de
pensar de que sería fácil poder producir
y distribuir a gran escala las vacunas y
que quizá se subestimó la capacidad de
producción de este
y ahora si la frontera legend ha
anunciado cambios para que la agencia
europea del medicamento pueda aprobar
las vacunas con mayor rapidez además
también ha admitido su culpa a causa del
error de activar la cláusula en irlanda
del norte que podría poner en peligro el
acuerdo de werner santo a cosa del
mecanismo de bloqueo de exportación de
vacunas ahora sí se podría decir que usó
la razón der leyen ha aceptado airosa el
examen de la eurocámara a pesar de que
se esperaban críticas muchísimo más
duras por parte de los diputados y de
esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continúan con nosotros un
día para todos
[Música]
rf